[موسيقى]
حسب خبرتي في مجال الحلاقه
بممتاز في الحلاقه من من تقريبا 18 سنه زي
ما اخبرتك وهاي الامور اعطتني ارضيه عند
الزباين وخبره وثقه انه يقدر الزبون يثق
في استخدام النار كانت طريقه قديمه
مستحدثه كانت الطريقه من زمان كتير كتير
وكانت الحلاقين بيستخدموها في اكثر من
طريقه انا انا عملت على تطوير النص لانه
درجه الحراره كانت بتساعدني على على فرد
الشعر
للزبونه
قبل ما اعمل الامور زي هذه لازم اخذ
الحميات اللازمه
هاي الامور ملهاش علاقه بالشعر ما بتحرق
الشعر ما بيطلع ريحه للشعر هي بتاخد على
على فرد الشعر الحراره بتاخد على تمدد
الشعره باخذ من درجه من درجه النار حراره
معينه بتصل للشعره تبديها شكل جميل شرط
بصوره كبيره على شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
ولقيت قبول الفكره كانت رائعه اقبال عليها
مميز الناس حبت تجربها فاحنا طريقه النار
اللي احنا بدنا نوصله انه احنا اشتغلنا
على طريقه كتير بسيطه الناس هي مش خطره هي
الموضوع ما له علاقه بالحلاقه هي موضوع
الشعر فرد الشعر تصفيف الشعر شيء جميل
بقدر اني اقدمه ونوصل للناس رساله انه
الشعب الفلسطيني شعب مبتكر الشعب كتير
راقي شعب عنده كفاءات عاليه جدا جدا
[موسيقى]